barely three months after the end of
China's strict covert zero policy the
government has declared a decisive
victory in the battle against the virus
president Xi Jinping presided over a
meeting where officials said 200 million
people had been treated for the virus
and the country's death rate was the
lowest in the world but analysts say
China's covid-19 data is suspiciously
low according to official figures about
80 000 people have died Nationwide from
the virus but researchers say the true
tally may be more than one million that
number one million or more that could be
a much lower number if if there was a
better preparation and possibly better
timing for the the transition away from
zero covert
beijing's sudden easing of restrictions
in December resulted in overwhelmed
morgues and patient wards authorities
only counted debts that occurred in
hospitals and approached the World
Health Organization says is inaccurate
the who has also canceled a planned
second phase investigation into the
origins of the pandemic citing
challenges in conducting the study the
United States energy Department says the
outbreak was most likely triggered by a
laboratory leak Beijing denies this and
says the pandemic has been politicized
the relevant parties should stop stir
frying the argument of a laboratory
League stop vilifying China and stop
politicizing the issue of origin tracing
as with the source of the pandemic the
true extent of the impact of China's
recent wave of infections remains
unknown this empty space used to be full
of people queuing at coronavirus testing
booths at the height of the zero covered
policy millions of people were tested in
the capital every day single cases
stopped neighborhood lockdowns but the
government did away with all of that at
the end of last year just as the country
was experiencing an explosive outbreak
in January a government Health official
suggested 80 percent of China's 1.4
billion strong population had already
been infected some experts believe this
may have been the fastest spread of
respiratory pandemic virus in modern
history
Al Jazeera Beijing